foreign
good morning to all of you thank you
very much for being here
it is a pleasure to welcome you all to
today's MV public hearing on the
European citizens initiative
for safe cruelty free Cosmetics commits
to Europe without animal testing
in association with other two committees
it is the committee on agriculture and
rural development and also the committee
on petition and with members of the
committee on Industrial Research and
energy which are invited
this European citizens initiative
collected over 1 million verified
signature from many different member
states which is a significant
accomplishment in particular I would
like to welcome
the European citizens initiatives
organizer and the experts who are here
with us today for this important hearing
I would like also to welcome and thank
for the good cooperation our colleague
Robert Nils chair of the committee on
agriculture and rural development and
also Yana tomb Vice chair of the
committee on petition and they will join
us later
of the committee of the petition and the
issue will share the hearing
afterwards the aim of today hearing is
to give the organizer of the European
citizens initiative a platform to
publicly present their initiative and to
engage in and constructive debate
and by saying this I would like to say a
warm welcome
the vice president of the European
commissioner responsible for values and
transparency for accepting our
invitation to deliver an opening
statement today we will have three
panels on today's hearing
which will allow us to gain a
comprehensive understanding of these
European citizens initiative the first
one is under the topic protect and
stagnant the Cosmetics animal testing
ban which will be chaired by Mr Lentz
the second is transform EU chemical
regulation will be there by myself and
the third is modernized science in the
EU which will be shared by Dolores
monseraci will come later and now I will
hand over to my colleague lince and then
to my colleague Tom thank you very much
good morning
good morning to my colleague Miss
spiriaki to my colleague from the
petitions committee
just like to wish you all a warm hello
to this hearing
Miss spiraki
already talked about the content of this
petition this successful citizens
initiative there's three main points
which is to protect and reinforce
the ban on animal testing
and the chemicals regulation
and
to modernize science in the EU
in the agricultural committee
I can tell you that the topic of
Animal Welfare is something that is high
on our agenda
keeping livestock and animals is
something that is part of our remit and
we want to and can improve that and
that's why I'm convinced that by
combining our forces we can work
together
and we have to do that
to find the best way for sustainable
Animal Welfare and to respond to EU
citizens needs so we are looking forward
to this exchange of opinions and that's
why I would like to now give the floor
over to my colleague from the petitions
committee
thank you very much thank you for
college distinguished commissioner
honorable colleagues
it's a great pleasure to see that the
citizen initiative received the support
of 1.4 million Europeans the tool of
initiative itself gives visibility to
Citizens initiatives and makes their
voices heard
uh all these aspects are essential in
participatory democracy or whose
principles the European Union is trying
to commit and more and more
the pity commission received several
petitions on this topic of animal
testing for cosmetics and in science in
general European petitioners are showing
great attention commitment and the high
accessibility in view to plotting a
roadmap to phase out all animal testings
in the EU before the end of the current
legislative term I want to remark on an
interesting point about this European
citizens initiative one of the
objectives of the initiative Banning
animal testings in the Safety Research
of Cosmetics is already a reality in the
EU thanks to the 2009 EU Cosmetics
regulation however the organizers are
worried that the latest EU strategy on
chemical could lead to possible
exceptions or work workarounds on this
ban
what we're seeing in this initiative
being used as a way to react to the
political discussion in Brussels and to
send a message of support to the current
level of ambition in raised by law the
other objective of this initiative is
ensuring that animal testing will not
longer be used for any kind of chemical
research despite an EU commitment to
ultimately replace all scientific
procedures using animals and research
education and Regulatory testing we see
that we are nowhere close to achieve
this goal
so we're looking forward for interesting
and fruitful discussion and now I'm
happy to give the floor to commissioner
thank you very much honorable chairs
honorable members dear organizers uh
thank you for the invitation to come and
speak on behalf of the European
commission at this public hearing
organized for the European citizens
initiative safe growth free Cosmetics
commit to Europe without animal testing
it is a real pleasure to be here again
today to engage in a debate on another
success successful initiative and I am
twice happy to be here because I see the
faces uh I see the organizers here we we
really had very very useful I think more
than two hours almost three hours of
very very useful exchange I learned a
lot and as you know I am the master of
the process I will be followed by by my
colleagues who are responsible for the
content but uh I want to repeat what I
already said at the hearing at the
commission because I want to repeat a
warm congratulations to the organizers
and all the supporters of this
initiative who have successfully
collected over 1.2 million valid
statements of support across the EU with
minimum thresholds and no less than 21
member states congratulations
this impressive achievement proves the
commitment of many engaged citizens
across our Union to campaign for their
ideas to make an impact these are the
moments that bring the most Joy seeing
participatory democracy work in practice
and if we translate the success of the
European citizens initiative into some
figures we see that safe cruelty free
Cosmetics is the ninth successful
initiative since the initiative
says this tool was launched and the
fifths in a row related to Animal
Welfare or environment last months we
replied to the initiative safe bees and
farmers and in July we will answer also
to the stop Finning initiative
this underlines the interests of
citizens in the well-being of both our
animals and our environment
we have seen that these successful
initiatives do generate long-term
effects on EU policies examples of a
direct follow-up to Citizens initiatives
are the revised drinking water directive
or the regulation on the transparency
and sustainability of the EU risk
assessment in the food chain
it is true that turning an idea into
legislation takes time we cannot take
shortcuts when making laws and time is
always needed to find compromises to
ensure broad support for our policies
our revised rules for European citizens
initiatives are also delivering results
since these new rules started to apply
in 2020 the commission has been able to
register 30 new initiatives I am also
happy to share with you that last months
we registered 100 citizens initiative
aiming at connecting Europe through a
high-speed train Network
to ensure that citizens are aware about
this important instrument we continue to
raise awareness through various means
including social media promotions events
and podcasts series raising awareness of
young people about how they can engage
in the Democratic processes of the EU
from an early stage is also something
that we strive for your organizers your
initiative is an important contribution
to the ongoing debate about animal
testing the commission gives High
importance to ideas submitted via the
European citizens initiative and we take
all successful initiatives very
seriously
uh today the commission is here to
listen All attentively to all the
contributions and interventions from the
organizers stakeholders and of the
members of the European Parliament to
get a very good understanding of the
initiative and collect all the views
which will help us prepare the most
appropriate response I wish you a
fruitful discussion and thank you for
the attention
thank you very much Madame commissioner
for your participation in this exchange
and also thank you very much for giving
us specific examples of pieces of
legislation based on commission on
people's initiative I will go ahead by
giving the flow to Sabrina anger
representing people for the ethical
treatment of animals
Peta from Germany
see online
we are here thank you very much for
being here in the room
thank you
as chair of the organizing committee I'd
like to thank you for having us here
today and I would like to start by
telling you the story of how this ECI
came to be
in October 2014 the European chemicals
agency and the European commission
released a joint statement signifying
that under certain circumstances
cosmetic ingredients may still be tested
on animals
this news came just 18 months after the
full implementation of the Cosmetics
testing and marketing bands and sparked
outrage across Europe
years of campaigning followed but as
policy did not change and the number of
dead animals increased the five largest
animal protection organizations in
Europe came together with a proposal for
an ECI
through our discussions together we
realized that the future of moving away
from animal testing hung in the balance
because the number of used animals was
stagnating there were even threats for
further testing and the implementation
and use of non-animal methods was moving
forward very slowly yet innovation in
science and in non-animal test methods
was rapidly advancing
so all these facts showed very clearly
to us that urgent action needed to be
taken and in August 21 we launched our
ECI with the support of many other
animal protection organizations and with
support of the cruelty-free brands the
body shop and stuff
together we sparked a movement around
Europe and yeah with the aim of a
meaningful change for animals
with three specific objections
objectives each addressing a specific
problem and proposing pragmatic
solutions to improve the lives of EU
citizens and animal protection we hope
you agree with us and the over
1.2 million supporting citizens that our
initiative is full of opportunities
and I'll pass you over to Reineke who
will tell you more about our vision for
a better Europe
good morning honorable members of this
house
dear vice president
um the world as we have created it is a
process of our thinking it cannot be
changed without changing our thinking
this ECI is a story about old and new
thoughts and about how you as
representatives of EU citizens play an
essential role in calling on the
European commission to open a new
scientific Paradigm one that will
benefit the animals humans and science
alike
as you may know animals have been
intensively used since the enlightenment
you see scientists such as Descartes
Elementary
using animals and they considered
animals as machines unable to feel any
pain or distress
and ever since billions of animals have
been used for fundamental research for
Education later on for safety testing
and it is difficult to change traditions
and to share to shift a whole mentality
and this mainly for this reason that
although we know now that animal based
research has serious limitations and the
potential to cause severe suffering a
distill regarded as the golden standard
by many scientists as exemplified by the
curricula of biomedical Sciences
luckily animals are no longer considered
as machines as you know very well in
this house citizens deeply Care About
Animals As showcased by this ECI but
also I'm sure you know that out of the
knowing successful ECR is five are
related to animals
and two call for transition to
non-animal science
so this is a very clear statement on top
of that opinion polls consistently show
wide support for the cause of this ECI
so 77 of EU citizens want a transition
to non-animal science
in addition to that scientific thinking
has also evolved
scientists agree that animals are
sentient beings able to feel stress pain
and much more than that animals are able
to have positive emotions such as joy
and pleasure
and as you know the EU has recognized
this in Article 13 of its treaty and has
acknowledged animals asantean beings
however the daily reality of laboratory
animals is very different they are not
able to express their natural behaviors
for example dogs are not able to go
outside and they suffer tremendously
whilst they undergo these painful
procedures
on top of this many scientists are now
questioning the scientific validity of
animal-based methods as famously quoted
by Professor Thomas Hartung a human is
not 70 kilo rat
um the translatability and
reproducibility of animal-based studies
for human purposes were much lower than
Advanced non-human methods for example
on average 92 percent of a clinical
trials fail to demonstrate safety and
efficacy after having passed most of the
times tests involving animals
and this is why more and more scientists
are exploring
non-animal approaches human-based
approaches such as organ on the chip
computer modeling human trials which
have proven to be a lot more effective
at protecting and advancing human health
you may wonder the EU has not been
unresponsive to these societal and
scientific views and gain the reputation
AS Global leader on Animal Welfare
the animal experimentation directive
aims at fully replacing the use of
animals and requires researchers to
always consider a non-animal method
before turning to animal-based research
and with sites Banning the use of
animals for cosmetic substances
um the EU has set up Egg farm and is
investing in a lot of initiatives to
support the development of alternatives
so why I have to interrupt you because
you have only five minutes time I would
like to ask you all please to stick at
your time slot thank you yes I will wrap
up
yeah
proceed by giving the flow to my
colleague chair of the agriculture
committees please Robert yeah please
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
and now this brings us on to the first
panel
the headline of this panel is protect
and strengthen the Cosmetics animal
testing bam
the
ecio organizers now have an opportunity
to sketch out their objectives for this
part of the hearing we've set aside 15
minutes for this
and we start with Dr Julia Baines from
Peter UK
and I have to point out I'm afraid that
you you just have the 15 minutes for the
presentation
and then we'll have question answers
from the members and then you have an
opportunity to come back go ahead
thank you very much
as you'll be well aware the EU Cosmetics
regulation established an important
president worldwide for assessing the
risks of cosmetic products and
ingredients without testing on animals
yet we're in a position today where the
ingredients continue to be tested on
thousands of animals so first I'd like
to show you a short reminder of why
Cosmetics tests on animals must end and
I should warn you might find the
following images and the sounds a little
glitter dressing please play the video
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
so we've clearly gone a full circle
since implementation of the Cosmetics
regulation in 2013 when we thought we
were witnessing the end to animal
suffering for Cosmetics sold in the EU
because in 2014 Echo and the commission
issued a joint statement announcing that
substances used exclusively in cosmetics
may be tested on animals for the
assessment of Workforce exposure during
the manufacturing process for substances
used in cosmetics and other types of
products tests on animals are permitted
regardless of any worker exposure risk
as a result the testing and marketing
bans which you helped to achieve are
being destroyed yet ending Cosmetics
tests on animals remains an important
priority to all of us not least members
of this Parliament because you pass the
global Cosmetics testing ban resolution
in 2018 and again in 2020 and 21
signaled your wishes for such tests to
end in your resolutions on the chemical
strategy for sustainability and the
action plan to accelerate animal-free
research so I asked how many times do we
need to ask for this to stop we Face
hurdle after hurdle 2020 saw the
culmination of two Echo Board of appeal
cases in which a German ingredient
supplier contested the way in which
reach was being used to circumvent the
animal testing ban sadly those testing
decisions were upheld and the company is
now appealing in the EU courts
and we're not just talking about one or
two tests a report published in 2021
shows that animals have been used in 104
new tests under reach since the bans
were implemented these tests include eye
irritation in which rabbits may be
restrained in stocks and have substances
applied directly to the surface of their
eyes acute toxicity tests which rats may
be force-fed the substance daily for
weeks on end and reproductive and
developmental tests which experimenters
may force feed hundreds of rabbits or
rats and ingredients throughout their
pregnancy
the reasons for protecting the animal
testing Banner clear we're talking about
the destruction of thousands of animals
restricting the rights of consumers to
buy cruelty-free products
upholding legislative values and
addressing additional threats through
the chemical strategy now no one is
disputing the necessity to ensure
protection of humans including both
workers and consumers and this can and
should be done without animal testing so
unsurprisingly citizens Cosmetics Brands
ingredient suppliers and even the court
of justice are now questioning
compliance with the testing ban
so how can we achieve our first
objective to protect and strengthen the
ban
well for Cosmetics ingredients to be
truly animal test three we call on the
commission to explicitly clarify that
worker safety comes under the scope of
the Cosmetics regulation this is because
the regulation aims to protect human
health and this must be taken to include
both workers and consumers
because we are all Human After All
our next recommendation
is for environmental toxicity assessment
of Cosmetics ingredients to also come
under the scope of the Cosmetics
regulation and this is what we mean by
strengthening the ban
the regulation allows for environmental
toxicity assessment to be achieved under
the provisions of reach and in doing so
allows for animal testing but instead we
should be looking to maximize the use of
currently available information
and also incentivize the development of
non-animal methods where necessary
because it's time the regulation caught
up with the science
next we urge the commission to protect
the animal testing ban within upcoming
legislative changes in the context of
the chemical strategy and this involves
ensuring that any proposed legislative
revisions impacting both the testing and
the classification of Cosmetics are
consistent with the animal testing ban
and we look to prioritize the
implementation and development of
non-animal methods for any additional
hazard classes where data gaps persist
for example endocrine disruption
finally the scientific committee on
consumer safety has long-standing
valuable expertise in using non-animal
methods for risk assessment
upcoming legislative changes which could
affect the committee must protect their
independence and Innovative position
because this would ensure that any
scientific evaluations related to safety
Cosmetics are carried out without
recourse to new tests on animals
so the EU Cosmetics animal testing ban
has been recognized as the gold standard
and incentive for transition and
innovation without animals and we must
not lose this progress
and I'd now like to hand over to Dr
Julia Phantom head of unilever's site
safety and environmental Assurance
Center to talk to you more about
ensuring safety without animals
good morning
thank you
um I think it's important that we see
this ECI in the context of having
regulations which promote both better
human health and Environmental
Protection and better animal protection
Unilever hopes that the high level of
support from EU citizens for the CCI
means that as a minimum relevant EU
policies and regulations will be changed
so that they facilitate transparency and
compliance with the key legislative
principle that any animal testing is as
a last resort that isn't the case today
the Cosmetics ban
um the testing ban in 2009 was a very
important stimulus for big advances in
non-animal Safety Science and the
development of the new toolbox that we
now have for assessing consumer worker
and environmental safety without resort
to new animal testing and as a scientist
toxicology who's responsible for product
safety I'm frustrated that the new
scientific approaches we use are not
more widely accepted for regulatory
safety purposes Beyond cosmetics and
consumers under the Cosmetics products
regulation
in my view this is actually a failure to
better protect EU citizens from chemical
exposures by using modern non-animal
safety signs and an increasing
proportion of the scientific Community
are now sharing this position and are
starting to speak up
traditional safety assessments are based
on animal testing but we add in
uncertainty factors of up to a thousand
to the animal data when we extrapolate
them to protect human health to
establish a safe exposure level
historically animal studies were the
only tools we had but that definitely
isn't the case today and it's rather
like still using horses as a routine
means of Transport even though we have
preferably electric cars and trains
the uncritical use of outdated animal
tests and the erroneous view that animal
tests are somehow a gold standard needs
to be challenged to a far greater extent
by decision makers
the U.S national academies will publish
their expert review of thousands of
animal tests on chemicals later this
year which from the initial results that
have been presented show that there is
poor reproducibility of the animal test
results between different studies on the
same chemical
safety scientists now have at the
disposal an animal-free scientific
toolbox Way Beyond anything I could have
imagined 20 years ago and much of this
is due to the U.S National Academy of
Science publishing a vision and a
strategy in 2007 for toxicity testing in
the 21st century
today we see the outputs from this
transformational change program being
implemented by the North American
Regulators for chemical risk assessment
purposes with health Canada the most
advanced in implementing the new
non-animal science-based approaches
rapid advances in science and technology
mean that we can generate much more
relevant safety data in larger amounts
and more quickly using Innovative
non-animal approaches and last week it
was good to see the scientific committee
on consumer safety publish their 12th
revision of the extensive notes of
guidance for safety evaluation of
cosmetic ingredients and this continues
to incorporate an increasing number of
advanced non-animal tests and and which
explains how these new approaches can be
applied in making decisions on the
safety of cosmetics
the sccs also clearly articulated the
challenge we have faced over the past
decade for cosmetic ingredients the
conflicting requirements of the animal
testing ban for Consumer safety in the
Cosmetics product regulation and the
explicit need for manufacturers of those
same ingredients to conduct animal tests
to comply with the reach chemicals
regulation
scientifically but also from a worker
safety perspective this doesn't make
sense makes it very difficult to uphold
the commitment that any animal testing
is as a last resort
the non-animal approaches we use to
demonstrate consumer safety can equally
be applied to assure worker safety where
chemical exposures are minimized through
the factory safety control measures in
place
I'd like to close on an optimistic note
over the past few years with the
chemical strategy for sustainability
incentivizing us there's been a lot of
creative thinking and many stakeholder
discussions on how best to modernize the
eu's regulatory approaches to chemical
safety including those chemicals used as
cosmetic ingredients next week the
European chemicals agency will hold a
workshop on transitioning to an
animal-free regulatory system for
industrial chemicals
I hope that this could be the Tipping
Point that some of us have been
advocating for
the echo background paper shows an
openness to rethinking past assumptions
and a positive view on short-term
regulatory changes in fact it states
it is possible to develop robust options
based on non-animal methods which can
provide protection levels comparable or
higher than the current ones for many
toxicological properties
there is now also more openness to
building new scientific capabilities in
non-animal approaches more broadly
across the industrial and Regulatory
communities
pioneering safe and sustainable
Innovation by Design without animal
testing is surely something that we can
all get behind alongside the
transparency and Regulatory preparedness
that are essential for building
confidence and implementing change
as a first priority we must tackle the
Cosmetics ingredients Challenge and
mandate the use of non-animal approaches
for worker and environmental safety as
well as for Consumer safety
that should have been done 10 years ago
let's not delay any longer
thank you
thank you very much thank you to Dr
Baines and Dr phantom for your
presentations now we'll turn to the
members of parliament to see if they
want to take the floor
we'll start with the Epp Mr paulcheck
thank you chair and please user use your
headphones because I'm speaking in Czech
um
thank you very much I'd like to thank
the people who initiated this
idea
and who are here I've been dealing for
quite a while now
with
Animal Welfare
but what we saw in your presentations
animal testing for cosmetics
where millions of tests are undergone
every year we have to ask the question
whether they're all necessary and
whether they have to be carried out
and surely they need to be done with a
minimum level of suffering for animals
and also there there must be
alternatives
I think without doubt
animal testing has led to advances in
the realm of Medicine
but when it comes to testing for
Cosmetics is concerned on animals I
wholeheartedly support your initiative
and I'd like to thank you all and
everybody who has supported you
I would like to underscore that we
should insist that European legislation
is applied
especially the 210 directive on
protective protection of
animals against
painful experiments
if Alternatives methods are available
they have to be chosen but that doesn't
always happen
in the past indeed there were attempts
to
carry out this sort of testing on
animals some areas of the community try
to avoid that
it's not necessarily the final
cosmetic product that is being tested
it's the ingredients
so I think there needs to be
a more consistent application of
legislation Banning tests so I have a
couple of questions
do we enjoy scientific certainty that
the ingredients and components used in
the Cosmetic products are indeed safe
our committee
deals with product safety
should your
initiative not be broadened not just to
do with the EU issues but also looking
at other partners as well around the
world
thank you please colleagues keep to two
minutes Mr Ferguson thank you very much
and I will speak in Danish
is not working
all right yeah the German is there but
the English is not
can we try again
[Music]
do it in English no I think it's
yep it solved Tim please go ahead it
works all right yeah yeah yeah
thank you very much I'll speak Danish
and I hope you can all hear me can you
hear me
can you hear me good
okay thank you very much I'll start from
the beginning
thank you for collecting these
signatures
I wish you every success in the future
I understand why so many people are
supporting this initiative because it is
indeed shocking
and I found the information you gave me
moving
animal
testing in the Cosmetics industry has
been banned in the EU since 2009 and for
various reasons for exemptions I hear
that they are nevertheless quite
extensive animal tests get carried out
animals are sentient beings that of
course is one issue but there's also a
democratic issue
because we said with a broad-ranging
majority that we do not want animal
testing in the Cosmetics industry
we have made that very clear in 2009 and
nevertheless it is still happening
this law there needs to be strengthened
so that we can phase out animal testing
just looking at the time frame maybe I
can put a question to you what is a real
realistic time Horizon
if we're to work as quickly as possible
and the commission comes up with a
proposal we in Parliament work speedily
on it
what does the time frame look like in
your mind
when the law could be changed
to get rid of these animal tests
obviously Alternatives will have to
exist
and the way I've understood it that
there are indeed many Alternatives but
how do you see a realistic timeline
thank you
is Frozen
okay I think our colleague Mr Metz like
my uh our colleagues Mets is outside so
Miss Rose please
wherever please
thank you chair
I would like to start by thanking the
initiators of this citizens initiative
European citizens initiative are crucial
for European democracy
and this is not the first time that
we're dealing with
Animal Welfare
and it's not the first time we've
reached a million signatures we reached
when it comes to live Vivid sections
as well as a shark fins
and soon
there'll be one for Europe without fur
where we're currently verifying the
amount of signatures
so it's obvious that European citizens
are concerned about animal welfare and I
hope that commission the commission can
rise to the challenge of this concern by
European citizens on Animal Welfare
in 2009 we had already banned cosmetic
testing on animals
and it will also banned the marketing of
products that had been tested or whose
ingredients had been tested on animals
now
I understand that the European chemicals
agency continues to ask some producers
to test products on animals if they want
to see their products accepted
and I'd like to know could the European
commission explain
how is this still possible
how are these requirements still allowed
when when it comes to cosmetic products
there is no reason for this to continue
it is illegal and the law must be
applied thank you thanks then the
colleague if you're cheap okay Mr
fyocchi please
this is my grip good morning Maria
[Music]
um
so in my opinion it might be very
controversial but if we have to save
human life then it's fine if we even
have to test on animals
I realize this is a tough thing to say
when it comes to medical issues we need
to be careful that a European regulation
against the use of
testing Cosmetics on animals
it might actually lead to a ban on
animal testing for medical purposes
so once again saving a human life is
worth a million animals
we have a beautiful
a picture
about this
for example I have a rat infestation at
home and we deal with it but we need to
give
value to human life it's not the same as
an animal life
I'd like to remind
our friend from Peta that every second
2400 animals are slaughtered
in order to feed the human population
so we should keep some perspective
what does it mean experimenting
for health reasons and what do we mean
by
feeding 8 billion human beings on this
planet
so I have to be extremely we have to be
extremely careful so as to not to limit
the possibility of animal testing
for
health reasons when it's for Cosmetics I
am completely in agreement with you
we should not cause suffering to animals
just to make cosmetics
but when it comes to health issues we
really need to be careful thank you
thank you thank you for colleague okay
and now our colleague Miss binyo
Mr President
thank you chair in 2009 Euro banned
animal testing for cosmetics in 2013 we
went further and we banned any products
that had been based on animal testing
now this continent thinks it's
progressing and we thought that this was
a definitive win however today and
despite our strong measures here the
European chemicals agency is calling
into question these principles by
demanding to
tests on animals for ingredients in
cosmetics so we're going backwards
we are forgetting our values we're
forgetting that the animals are sentient
beings animals suffer from and from
testing and this is why um
we had massive amounts of signatures in
this citizens initiative the commission
has six months to react we can't simply
respond with empty words we need to take
action
Europe has banned cosmetic tests on
animals we need to change the practices
of the European chemicals agency and we
need to uh protect both animal and human
lives and the environment
through this Democratic process
European citizens don't have a lot they
can do except for the citizens
initiative now two million of our fellow
citizens including 250 000 French
citizens have signed this this petition
this is an ethical issue we're asking
for concrete steps to be taken for
Animal Welfare let's do something once
and for all thank you thank you and now
our colleague Miss Aguilera
thank you chair
I'd like to thank you as did most of my
colleagues
for this citizens initiative
it definitely is an example of
transparency and democracy and
thank you for all the hard work you've
done now I have a few points here that
I'd like to to ask you
perhaps you could clarify since you
since you're experts in this field
you say
that this has already been banned which
is a step forward no doubt about that
but then there is a regulation
that allow some exceptions
and this is
in the case where there are no
alternatives
now
I'm not speaking about cosmetic
the cosmic industry I'm talking about
private and public Laboratories that
have told me that there are cases where
they still need the exception
so I'm saying this doesn't come from Big
Business this comes from scientists
so
I think that
there are diverging criteria
now I fully understand
that when we are looking for innovation
[Music]
and moving forward of course we should
test finish put an end to animal testing
whenever possible however we do need to
have some exceptions when
I as I understand there is no
alternative and it's acceptable so that
scientific Divergence that I see
is what might lead to this exception in
testing
on animals for Cosmetics so it would be
needed
this is my specific question perhaps we
could have a a moratorium a temporary
ban to make sure this doesn't happen
again
and we can say well this is such a date
will be the end of the exceptions and
from then on then we will have to
innovate and find Alternatives thank you
colleague
here chair ladies and gentlemen dear
colleagues
good morning
citizens initiatives are a good idea and
it's very
welcome that we talk about it and then
politicians have to react
in an adequate manner if there are other
possibilities to test products of course
we have to tap into this potential of
other possibilities and then we do not
use animals
we all use Cosmetics but this is not
essential for our lives
then let me mention a testing of
substances for medicines
um
are you against this as well here we
know that
any medicinal product has to be tested
on humans we heard this very often
during covet we always said how many
times we have to test a product on
people
and then I would like to ask a question
to our experts do we have adequate
testing
that can
equally replace animals
in case of testic substances for
medicinal products thank you
thank you
Ms Lee Mets killing mats thank you thank
you very much for giving me the flow I
hope that the commission will respond to
the request of
1.2 million citizens with a legally
binding act and proceed to include the
proposal for the revision of reach
solutions to completely end the
possibility of conducting animal testing
for cosmetic produce or their ingredient
under reach which we know does not
exclude animal testing unlike the
Cosmetic regulation this is a situation
of legal inconsistency it's causing
damage to the credibility of the
European Union the same European Union
that banned animal testing for cosmetic
products completely 10 years ago
becoming the first in the world now
founds itself having to discuss this
issue again and again the solution
exists it is only a matter of
identifying them and making them
operation and unable believe that this
is the responsibility of the European
Commission of course we could also now
question why in generally but especially
in cosmetics we use potential dangerous
ingredients and all and how many new
Cosmetics do we need indeed a parliament
resolution in support of this STI is
crucial but this step is not guaranteed
so we have to discuss this in our
political group in order to have such a
resolution supporting the ECI because
this issue does not belong to political
current but to all the citizens who have
believed 10 years now that there is no
animal testing on on behalf of Cosmetics
precisely because of European
legislation and in the last year we'd
have discovered us that this is not the
case at all it is important that the
association present here and the 1.2
million citizens feel support here of
the European institutions thank you
okay thank you if no one else wants to
take the floor
then I would like to go back to the
panel and
ask the organizers they each have five
minutes to react to the questions and
comments that they've heard please
thank you very much that was some very
interesting comments there so the
decisions that we make on chemical
safety for consumers workers and the
environment they must be based on the
best scientific data and knowledge
available because we've seen rapid
advances in biology in cell-based
Technologies assays in analytical and
compute approaches and these have led to
new types of Highly relevant scientific
data being generated so this isn't a
question of safety this is a question of
using the best available data that we
have because this helps us to improve
the safety decisions that we're making
whilst also enabling us to avoid animal
testing so for example Next Generation
risk assessment these approaches allow
us to integrate various types of
non-animal scientific data that have
been established for assessing the
safety of chemical ingredients used in
cosmetics and in other products and the
Cosmetic sector has been employing a
robust non-animal approach for many many
years the problem we are facing is in
ensuring that it is implemented across
different regulatory platforms because
we can't say that we have a ban under
one regulation but then allow the very
same testing on animals under another it
completely destroys the value of a
legislative procedure
and then just to address some of the
medical issues my colleagues will take
this up later on but we are talking
about advancing science having a
strategic plan to move Europe forward to
make sure that we are implementing the
best methods that we are replacing
animals at strategic points that we are
setting ourselves goals that we are
looking for those priority areas and
research where we can end tests on
animals now where we might need further
input in the development of further
non-animal methods and this is very much
a call to bring relevant stakeholders
together and work on an action plan so
we can move forward and progress within
Europe and I'd just like to hand over to
my colleague Julia do you want to say a
few words
uh thank you yes I think um the key
um challenges probably that we face and
are not so much scientific now so unlike
in 2003 in the Cosmetics directive
seventh amendment that uh first
introduced the timeline of 10 years for
a complete marketing ban we now have had
that time to develop the scientific
approaches the challenge that we're
facing is actually being able to use
those for regulatory purposes so I think
that is a bit of a different question
from where we were and where some of the
other questions are coming I um think in
terms of a there was a question about a
time frame and I think what we need to
consider is that there is you know there
are pockets of Leading Edge scientific
capability so it becomes a a training
and a capacity and an infrastructure
type of issue in terms of where the
investment needs to go to make sure that
actually both for each and for cosmetics
and other types of products we are
actually then able to use this uh this
modern science
thank you
thank you very much
so that ring now after the panel we've
got the commission who will take the
floor Mr Engel Mr Engels from DG grow
please
uh thank you very much to the members of
the committee in the European Parliament
to have organized this hearing and also
thank you very much to the organizers of
the initiative for being here and for
making your very interesting
presentations
uh first of all let me start with uh
sharing the ambition to phase out animal
testing this is challenge started in the
commission and this is also the feeling
that you have from the uh from the 2010
directive
but uh I'll talk to my response in in
two legs first of all we'll build legal
and then a social science
as far as the legal aspects are
concerned Cosmetics regulation already
prohibits animal testing you're already
explained it very quickly
um and that was also something which is
done which was done during a transition
period
now uh as far as we are concerned the
animal testing ban in the Cosmetics
regulation is carved in stone uh and in
Maya it was uh never ever as somebody
asked me to revise it so it's widely
accepted by the industry it's widely
accepted by everyone and I think it's
also very appreciated by the consumer
but we also have to admit the Cosmetics
regulation only covers human health of
the end users so there's a number of
aspects that are not covered by the
Cosmetic regulation Environmental
Protection for instance or protection of
workers it's not covered by the
Cosmetics regulation
it's covered by other pieces of EU
chemical legislation and indeed
the these pieces of legislation do not
require uh or do not prohibit animal
testing because ingredients that are
being used for Cosmetics can also be
used for other purposes
um and can so therefore
um for for these other purposes there's
still a possibility of animal testing
yet it's clear that if
ingredients are being used for Cosmetics
only then the Cosmetics band uh the
animal prohibition ban applies for the
Cosmetics regulation
now on the ridge because Cosmetics
ingredients also have to undergo reach
um which is uh requires or um which must
specifies that you can use animal
testing only as the last resort
uh it leaves the door open for animal
testing which is true
um the targeted revision of your age
regulation and this is something that we
will discuss also during the singer
panel uh aims at increasing the
available Hazard information uh also on
substances registers in the lowest
tonnage range and on endocrine
disruptors for all substances
this will lead to enhanced health and
Environmental Protection uh but it might
also have impacts on ML testing we have
to be honest here
um and this is something that we need to
explore
um in our response to the initiative and
also in the future less difficult table
and this is the legal aspect but we have
to rely on science also because we as a
European commission and the goals for
all the institutions we're also very
science driven and what counts for us
and which is urgent is the development
of alternative methodologies because
this is what we need
you cannot ban something but without
having a good alternative and indeed as
you pointed out it's it science is
making very rapid progress the
commission is working very closely with
a number of other bodies
first of all uh the agency but also the
joint Research Center which is very
active on alternative methods on
non-animal methods and also the uh
scientific comedy on consumer safety
sccs which is specialized in the safety
of cosmetics
we're working very closely together for
this development of these alternative
methods and they need to be validated
because it's important that these
methods are being accepted by everybody
who's involved in the safety assessment
of cosmetic ingredients
um Mr Phantom uh already pointed out we
we're organizing together with eka and
other stakeholders a seminar Workshop
that will take place through in the
first of May and the 1st of June and
that Workshop will discuss steps that
necessary to reduce animal testing for
all regulatory purposes in short and in
medium term and to reach the ultimate
goal of phasing out animal testing in
the long term
our formal response to your very
important initiative it will be table by
the end of July and uh you will see
we'll try to be as ambitious as we can
possibly be and the response will also
indicate further avenues for actions um
from our side thank you very much
feel nuts again thank you very much to
the commission that brings us to the end
of our panel panel
so thank you to everyone who took part
and now over to the second panel and
over to Maria please oh
thank you thank you very much well we
will go on to the second panel under the
topic ensure human health and the
environment are protected by managing
chemicals without the addition of new
animal text testing requirements I would
like to to give the flow to to the
representatives of the of the initiative
starting with Dr Emma Grant coming from
cruelty free Europe please
de floresios
thank you and good morning to all
members here today
a presentation
okay
great oh so the second ECI objective is
to transform European chemicals
regulations
on the right slide and I'd like to give
a little bit of context around animal
testing and two key chemical regulations
CLP and reach the CLP regulation
describes how data is to be used to
classify that is to formally describe
the hazards presented by chemical
substances and it is the reach
regulation which sets out what
information is legally required to be
supplied we are focusing on these two
regulations because the transition to
the exclusive use of non-animal methods
for generating regulatory data for
chemicals requires the co-evolution of
both of these regulations plus some
other supporting regulations now there
are barriers to the use of non-animal
data for describing chemical hazards
according to CLP the European
commission's 2019 Fitness check of this
regulation identified that
CLP lacks detail on the use of
non-animal data it needs to be updated
without delay and should at the very
least be brought into line with what has
been agreed internationally under the
unghs the United Nations globally
harmonized system where the use of
non-animal data to describe skin
corrosion eye corrosion and skin
sensitization hazards is explicitly laid
out
the long-awaited retrovision is due to
be published in quarter four this year
the supply of data underreach today
relies heavily on tests being conducted
on mice rats rabbits and fish and we
estimate that by 2019 over 2.6 million
animals will have been used in tests for
the purposes of this regulation and this
exceeds the worst case a number of
animals that was estimated by the
commission and can only have increased
since 2019 and we could expect a sharp
increase in the number of animals tested
on current proposals to amend chemical
regulations under the chemical strategy
for sustainability are implemented the
number of animals used for endocrine
disruption by our estimation could be as
many as 3.5 to 5 million animals
furthermore some were 1.6 million
animals could be used in tests related
to the registration of polymers taking a
long-term view the number of chemical
substances entering into the EU Market
is expected to rise substantially over
the next few decades now the impact on
animals goes beyond simply counting the
number of animals tested on the testing
of chemicals can lead to significant
suffering with animals forced to ingest
inhale or have chemicals apply to their
skin or eyes
and taking the period between 2015 and
2020 as an example using data held by
the commission we see that in 24 of all
tests performed for the purposes of
reach the animals experience severe or
moderate pain suffering or distress the
definition of moderate suffering can
include surgery and the associated
post-surgical pain suffering or
impairment of General condition whereas
severe suffering can Encompass many
effects including toxicity testing where
death is the end point we see that 821
tests where death is the endpoint were
conducted in the EU and nowhere in 2020
alone to meet the requirements of
European chemicals legislation
as the start of the as the state of the
art of the use of non-animal data for
regulatory decision-making advances the
reach regulation must allow for the
fullest possible use of non-animal
approaches for generating new data and
the CLP regulation must fully support
the use of such data to describe
chemical hazards and together these
regulations need to evolve for a
transition away from animal testing the
second ECI objective Targets this need
okay
we have outlined a three-point minimum
mandate relating to the second ECI
objective the first point is to put in
place concrete steps meaning with
dedicated resources meaningful timelines
defined and cross-sectoral support
enabled to develop and Implement human
and environmentally relevant
non-animal approaches for identifying
toxic chemicals
the second point is to ensure that the
rapid uptake of non-animal approaches is
aligned between the European agencies
responsible for chemicals biocides plant
protection products Pharmaceuticals and
other products the last Point expresses
that we do not want to see a defaulting
to Reliance on animal testing under
European regulations as they stand today
or in the future deadlines for the
supply of data through testing on
Animals by default should not be applied
at the expense of scientific rigor or
human and environmental safety
considering the often poor performance
of animal tests and the unquantified
uncertainties associated with the data
that they produce
so I'll hand over now to my colleague
Donna who is online and she will talk
about how such a mandate can be
translated into action
is remotely I suppose
yes okay a warm welcome from Brussels
thank you uh thank you Emma and good
morning to to everyone I am in the room
next slide please
um so how can we achieve the minimum
mandate that I am adjusted described our
first recommendation is the creation of
an expert scientific committee with
significant expertise in non-animal
methods this committee would provide
independent advice and a recommendations
on suitable non-animal methods as well
as being able to provide inputs into any
review of current practice
including a upcoming revisions of um
regulations
this would lead to increased compliance
uh leading to a decrease on the burden
on the European chemicals agency and
then of course a decrease in the number
of animals used next slide please
our second recommendation is to increase
the uptake and implementation of
non-animal methods the the European
commission has invested many millions of
Euros in funding for the development of
technologically advanced non-animal
methods this hasn't led to a material
change in their acceptance by Regulators
now part of this is down to the the
structure of regulations like reach
um and because of this the the first and
arguably most crucial part of this
recommendation is to ensure that the
regulations are future proofed this
includes adding flexible language that
allows the use of scientifically valid
non-animal methods when available and of
course to avoid the need to reopen these
regulations in the future in order for
them to advance
um next a regular review of the oh sorry
thank you a regular review of the
availability the uptake and the
implementation of non-animal methods
which could of course be done under
recommendation one the expert scientific
committee that should be supported
and Regulatory Frameworks must be
adapted to ensure the rapid uptake of
non-animal methods
this can include the um been able to use
tiered testing strategies under reach as
it currently stands or been able to use
prioritization approaches under a
reformed or revised um reach
and this can all be achieved by
implementing clear milestones
um
clear goals key performance indicators
and all of these will be discussed a bit
more in the the next section on the
third objective of the the ECI in next
slide please
and so just before I conclude it's
important to note that there are
non-animal methods available or under
development for all toxicity endpoints
the required assessment under a
chemicals regulations
and the only way to not default to
animal models is to commit to a full
transition away from animal testing by
ensuring that no further new or expanded
animal test based data requirements are
added to regulations
and by doing this we'll achieve a win
for industry for human health and the
environment and of course for the
animals used in these tests in a hope
that we have your support
I'll now hand over to Professor Jose
tarazona from the Spanish National
Environmental Health Center who'll be
describing how this paradigm shift in
chemical safety assessment can be
achieved using Next Generation chemical
risk assessment thank you
thank you very much for your very
interesting presentation I think that
now we are able to have in online and
thank you very much for your connection
Professor Jose Arizona
he's coming from the Spanish National
Environmental Health Center Institute of
De saluto Carlos Madrid
so Professor you have the floor everyone
will come from Brussels
thank you very much thanks a lot for
inviting me to give my my ideas
unfortunately I cannot be present there
but there is always an honor to speak to
the members of the European Parliament
after 13 years in the European
institutions both in the European
chemicals agency and the European Food
Safety Authority I'm now in the back to
research in Spain as you can see in the
disclaimer of the slide that is what I
will present is my personal view based
on my experience not experience of the
institutions
next slide please
basically to summarize the methodology
that we have now for chemical risk
assessment in the area of Toxicology we
have two different approaches one is the
use of animal models this is the
methodology that was developed in the
20th century the last century based on
what was available there you need to
have a
experimental animals and what the the
methodology was developed to look at
adversity in those animals based on what
was available at that moment 70 years
ago on a clinical effects biological
biochemical effects sorry
histopathological effects
uh later on toxicology has the developed
the current of psychology what they call
the 21st century toxicology is mostly
based on emitter models organoids in
both cases you need an extrapolation but
obviously the circulation is different
you need to extrapolate from the animal
to humans
in one case and you need to do
extrapolation from this in vitro cell
methods to real life humans in in the
second case but it's important to
mention that extrapolation is needed in
both cases next slide please
if you look to research in toxicology in
the area of chemical risk assessment you
could you can see that over 80 percent
of the current toxicological research is
based on this this new Innovative
Innovative approaches but nevertheless
when you look at what is used in the
regulatory context this new
methodologies is really still integrated
in the chemical risk assessment not only
in Europe but the
also elsewhere it's in the world next
slide please
if you as early successful what are the
main reasons the more typically
explanations are summarized in this
slide first is that there is no
experience they did not have experience
or have used this information or there
is no guidance it's important to mention
that this is the typical IBC cycle and
there is no guidance because we need the
experience for the guidance and we will
never get the spirits if we do not start
to use this any methodologies in the
system
and the second main element that is
argued to not use these methods is that
there is a lack of standardization on
harmonization of the methods next slide
please
nevertheless it's important to have the
full picture to see other examples for
example in the area of a genotoxicity we
already have a very Consolidated pathway
that moves starting first got all
available information whatever it is
then only in bitter methods and use in
Vivo
animal methods only when that is there
really needed and for genotoxicity they
have been Consolidated for the years is
a common practice and it's important to
mention that in this case one of the of
the specific elements for genotoxicity
is a qualitative element but also it's
based on the mechanisms of the
genotoxicity
regarding the second element as has been
already mentioned there has been a huge
investment in the standardized in a
standardization in vitro methods uh
mostly driven by the need for a
Cosmetics thanks ahead to the Cosmetic
regulation but also covering other
elements like endocrine disturbs and
origin of toxicity you have a hearing
summary of uh most of the methods that
have been developed by the oecd or in
vitro methods next slide please
if you ask what is my idea why this new
methodology is not Incorporated I had
tried to to put the the my view with
this example what we are using today in
the chemical risk assessment is still
the Paradigm that was developed in the
1950s it's a paradigm based on animal
testing and observation of adverse
effects in the animals then you see what
is the maximum dose that do not produce
any adverse effects that you can observe
in the animal and then apply a factor
normally a factor of 100 to assume that
this is a level should be safe for
humans
when you compare the kind of information
that is produced by this new methodology
the 21st century methodology is
absolutely different the idea is to
understand
what is the interaction between the
chemical and the biological systems a
cellular sub cellular even molecular
level so what what their researchers are
producing are looking to effects at
intermediate endpoints effects not at
the of the full in Vivo system but yes
to understand the mechanisms and then
these mechanisms is moving to Pathways
for adversity to extrapolate what should
be the consequences for human health in
case that the the humans are exposed at
these levels
obviously if you have a this email with
the Petrol gas if you go now with a new
electric car to an 1950 a petrol gas
station that you have only petrol you
can never connect the electric car here
next slide please
there are solutions Sciences
always looking for Solutions and if you
have a petrol station and you can now
always have a generator create the
electricity and then connect your car
this is what I call the Paradigm
Evolution we can integrate this new
methodologies keeping the current
paradigm this will imply use all the
system animal information but instead of
conducted new animal testing to
integrate this with in vitro
methodologies and at least do the
comparison
this new methodologies are very useful
for us during the the safety of
chemicals for workers and consumers and
citizens in general they can
identify effects that cannot be seen in
the animals because obviously the animal
tests are not a perfect effect like the
developmental neurotoxicity or other
neurotoxicity that are very difficult to
be observing the animals there are also
other human specific diseases that they
obviously can be covered by the human
models but they can be covered with this
in bitter method so that should be
always a possibility can also identify
something that from the human health
perspective is very relevant identify
groups in the population that have a
specific susceptibility and also
interaction between different chemicals
and that may require combined
assessments and obviously this approach
I will facilitate to get an experience
in using this new methodologies in
chemical risk assessment and to produce
the proper guidance next light please
but what I would suggest is moved faster
than that and also deeper and go to the
this is the Paradigm Revolution
again with the example if we have an
electric car we do not need to use
petrol we can use other tools and other
options much more sustainable to get the
electricity and plug in or a or electric
car this imply Thinking Out of the Box
the box that is a very nice Paradigm
that has been worked a lot during 70
years but was developed based on what
was available 70 years ago what
toxicologists were able to do 70 years
ago we are much more better methods
today
there are some elements that has been
already integrated for example at the in
the echa and FSA guidance on endocrine
disruption
for the assessment of sun effects this
approach of using available in vitro
mechanistic information and moved to
individual mechanistic information only
when needed was already there and there
is a clear indication that for the
estrogenic modality in bitter
methodologies it should be sufficient to
confirm their safety for the chemicals
in this particular modality and this was
already 70 years ago so there had been a
lot of evolution in science
next slide please
so what they could suggest that they
what they need in this decade
a risk assessment alternative is to
focus first on the integrated approach
obviously you have a huge amount of
animal data that that has been conducted
that must be used
but the idea is to use what is available
record animal data and other kind of
informations and complement the gaps as
quickly using non-animal methods
particularly human in bitter models on
other assessments and with the current
methodology this can be supported with
the in silica methodologies to do the
read across from the chemicals we have
animal data to the chemical that we
don't have complemented with in vitro
methodologies for both and also
supported by the artificial intelligent
methods that they may facilitate the
incorporation of the huge amount of
embiological knowledge that has been
developed in the areas of biology and
physiology
so this egg will allow a new approach
using different lines of evidence for
doing the extrapolation with the focus
of identify the drivers for the groups
in the population that are more
vulnerable for this to a particular
chemical
next slide please
so basically the Dilemma that we need to
to consider if we want to keep
the whole Paradigm single human
guideline value based on animal studies
that can be supported by by something
else but keep this Paradigm or develop a
new strategy
that is adapted to the current
scientific knowledge basically is to
repeat today what was done 70 years ago
when the scientists and toxicologists
and resources are joined together put
the effort to see with the methodology
that we have what is the best way to
have a risk assessment to protect the
citizens
and if we repeat this today we will be
able to adapt to this new paradigm that
will identify the drivers for protecting
the most vulnerable population groups as
well as the the environment
and just to finalize please remember
it's not only Animal Health and Animal
Welfare is to improve safety assessments
over the current scientific knowledge
next slide thank you very much
thank you professor and thank you very
much for giving us this scheme that we
have to consider how can we reduce and
finally phase out animal testing we will
go on to q a with our colleagues members
of the of the committee starting with my
colleague penile Vice from EVP
magnet Chuck yeah
thank you very much uh take the
opportunity to speak Danish in fact in
this very important hearing
this is a very serious topic of course
and I would like to thank everybody for
the important contributions we've heard
already
I think the proposal has been put in a
very constructive manner
in terms of what we can do and what is
in fact necessary for the future
when we're looking at the Cosmetics
industry
of course you could deem this to be
superfluous
they've been technological developments
that must be taken advantage of
but there is one aspect I haven't heard
too much about I'm a member of the
industry committee as well that's why
I'd like to put a question
as to which other initiatives
are needed apart from a speedy revision
of reach
better cornerstones
better orientation guidance
which
other
research-based proposals
do you think we should be looking at
in the environment committee
obviously
it's easy for us to agree that things
should change
but it has to go through
Society has to be changed in industry in
the population and that they're subject
to International competition so how can
we help these companies to make sure
that they can generally find New
Alternatives that can be used and so
that they can genuinely bring a stop to
animal testing
without these companies being
subject to a loss of competitiveness
because that's also something we need to
consider I.E that International level
they have to remain competitive there's
a form of support or help to facilitate
these tests or Technologies
so that that can happen
we have to do this all together thank
you
thank you benil and I would like just to
ask you to stick on one minute and a
half this is the time slot for the
members I will go ahead to our colleague
telemeds from greens thank you
[Music]
thank you very much for giving me the
floor so we heard and we all know that
the EU chemical strategy for
sustainability uh as foreseen right now
will increase we'll ask even for more
animal testing we also heard that there
is definitely a lack of data on
non-animal testing we know that fish
frogs are sensitive to underground
disruption but also to pain there we are
possibilities to work with for example
fish embryos it's still not ideal but
it's advancing there are also other
non-new alternative methods in Virtual
human cells work directly
so yes we need tasks to protect humans
and animals but not on animals so what
we need now is really prioritize
validation and promotion of the
so-called nams non-animal testing new
approaches mythologies we need coherent
political decision we need from
something looking at Horizon right now
there is I think a zero port wine that
is dedicated to non-animal testing
methods we have in the Europe agencies
like Egg farm that are doing active
research on animal testing we need
therefore also better coherence better
cooperation amongst scientists we need
training so please let's stop playing
environment and human health Defenders
against those who are defending animals
because we need testing yes but without
animal tests animal suffering to improve
as we'll say right now safety assessment
with current scientific knowledge and
also considering that other countries
that the United States of America are
really considering Banning testing on
and on mammals and explicitly really
Foster also the new alternative
methodologies so yes we need to identify
an endocrine disruptors critical hazards
properties of ingredients
that can harm our nervous system and our
immunity but we need to use the
scientific current knowledge and to
better share that knowledge thank you
very much
before I give the flower to Aurelia
beignet to our colleague from idea I
would like to ask you to express your
interest on cats VI
Olivia please the floor is yours yes
now this European initiative was
launched for a very simple reason
it is that we no longer want products to
be marketed based on animal testing this
should not happen in Europe only speak
of Cosmetics most of these are made in
Japan Japan Korea or the United States
so while this is a good step forward we
need to do more for non-european
products
and we need to find a way to to keep
tabs and all these imported products
will the measures penalize European
products while we continue to allow
foreign products in are we ready to put
in a place the same restrictions on all
products
crucially Europe must produce Cosmetics
while
following these bands but we should not
be the only ones to do so thank you
thank you and without having candy catch
the eye I would like to give the flow to
myself as a member of the MV committee
by thanking once again the organizer of
this very very important citizens
initiative in order to retaliate the
lack of implementation of the Banning
animal testing particularly in the
Cosmetic sector
allow me to say that although animal
testing is not a part A a narrow part of
the remit of of CLP but we will try to
include a provision concerning phase out
of animal testing in CLP and I would
like to to try for this answer I put
there of this regulation and also allow
me to retaliate but we have to to work
on a scientific based and like taking
into consideration the capacity of feca
meaning that scientific basis at the
hands of hacker and we would need also
to enhance the resources and also the to
enhance the financing to Echo in order
to address such kind of challenges thank
you very much once again and we will go
back to the reactions by the organizers
for five minutes thank you
thank you
thank you so much
um and thank you for all the
interventions and the questions and some
key points in those interventions I'm
really glad to hear that you feel our
proposal is constructive we certainly
aim for something that's pragmatic and
implementable and prioritizing the
validation of non-annual methods yes
this is crucial and certainly it doesn't
come for free it needs to be funded
there's work entailed in that endeavor
and we certainly do need training for
scientists and the use of non-annual
methods and that also extends to
Regulators too who need to be competent
in the use of non-animal data and
comfortable in making regulatory
decisions based on it uh we are happy to
hear for the support for including
animal testing or non-animal methods use
considerations into CRP and certainly
agree on the capacity issue at Echo is
the the critical implementing body for
chemicals and financing their operations
certainly is key the questions that I
picked up
uh so what other measures our
initiatives are needed as well as a
speedy revision of reach uh what the
research-based proposals are needed how
can companies be helped to use
non-annual methods and concerns
regarding the loss of competitiveness
internationally so I would respond
firstly by emphasizing we're not talking
about immediately ending all animal
tests for chemicals right now we talk
what we want is maximizing the use of
non-anmal methods today plus the rapid
introduction of new non-animal methods
and non-annual methods equals better or
equal to the protection we have today
and it's not about animals versus humans
that that's that's not uh the equation
that we need to consider regarding what
we need to do
um to develop and Implement these
relevant non-animal approaches uh
we really need to enable regulatory
decision making that's based on a
different kind of data
data that is not in the same form as
that is supplied by animal testing and
we are living with a legacy of
regulations that have been built on a
historical use of and current use of
animal testing and as far as helping
industry well we need to make it very
clear to Industry what non-animal
methods can be used and when they can be
used
certainly part of this work requires
that the animal tests that we have been
using for so long should be properly
scrutinized they have not been validated
to the level that's expected for new
non-annual methods today and a very
significant question marks surrounding
the performance of non-animal sorry of
animal testing methods for things like
endocrine disruption for example
uh thinking about uh
uh economic aspects well there is some
benefits for of us for contract research
organizations in
expanding into the supply of non-animal
testing uh tests and and also the new
test method developers industry can
benefit here if they embed the use of
non-animal methods into their
sustainability by Design thinking this
is really going to put industry on the
on the front foot and you know the
European market is always going to be
lucrative and that that is without doubt
and uh thinking about what happens
internationally I would point out that
increasing regulatory requirements for
non-animal data is increasing we see for
example South Korea have committed to a
phase out of animal testing for
chemicals the US and Canada they've made
a strong commitment to phase out of
testing on vertebrate animals by a 2035
I really am polite I would like this to
to remind you that you have five minutes
to respond but it is representing the
whole slot that we have on behalf of the
organizers so please because we have two
persons waiting uh
thank you uh okay well I as uh that's
the my part finished perhaps uh Donna
would you like to uh make an addition
uh yes thank you and I thank you my
first round passing over and I would
like to to thank um for uh thank
everyone for their interventions and for
the questions that have been asked and
for the the support
um given to to our section of um the the
ECI and um just to address one of the
the questions
um relating to validation and then
promotion of um non-animal methods
um I would like to think that the
Workshops the upcoming Airco Workshop
will be able to discuss some of these um
issues in a bit more
um detail
um and
um with respect to the promotion of
non-animal methods I do think that that
is a very important area to
um ensure that there are grants and
funding and incentives
um for labs custom research
organizations
um industrial Partners to to focus on
these
um instead of animal tests especially
for newer hazards like uh respiratory
sensitization where there may not be any
validated animal or non-animal tastes
available and I'll end there in case we
would like to add to anything thank you
thank you
thank you thank you very much for your
contribution to this very very
interesting panel I will now pass the
floor to my their calling and friend
of the committee oh sorry sorry
I was I was I was in a hurry and I I
forgot that the commission has the floor
and sorry for this
we would like to have the response on
behalf of the commission of Mr Orel see
you about there he's the director of
dgmv
yeah thank you very much and good
morning uh honorable members of the
European Parliament and ladies and
gentlemen initiators of these European
citizens initiative
um very interesting panel indeed and a
lot of information
also
illustrating a very strong Ambitions
from the initiators and it's an ambition
which is also shared by the European
commission I would like to reassure you
that we work in the same direction to
the maximum speed which is allowed by
science and speed and accuracy which
science allows so I would like to
reassure you that the commission does
not want to lay or maintain any
regulatory barrier that would
how to to say block a new methods for
from replacing the traditional animal
tests I would like to give you an
overview of what the commission is doing
to accelerate the transition away from
animal testing under the chemical
legislations in general some of the
actions have been mentioned here by some
of your guests or even by yourselves or
by my colleague Hans from Digi grow
earlier but for the sake of completeness
I would like to retain all the
information
we are continuously taking into account
newly available methods that reduce or
replace animal testing examples are
under the current reach regulation as it
stands information requirements that
replaced animal testing for skin and eye
irritation
an amendment based on an amendment of
the annexes seven and eight of the rich
regulation which has taken place in 2016
and skin sensitization an amendment in
2017 of annex 7. the chemical strategy
for sustainability which was adopted at
the beginning of this mandate by the
European commission contains a
commitment to establish and update a
research and Innovation agenda for
chemicals that promotes the regulatory
uptake of research findings this
includes a commitment to Foster
multidisciplinary research to move away
from animal testing and I think it is
fair to say that even if the chemical
strategy for sustainability it's a
political commitment of the current
College of the commission and one would
say that such policy papers and
political commitments
you would say
superficially they last as long as the
Federation of the Mandate of a college
this issue is of sufficient importance
to represent a lasting concern and area
of interest for the European commission
so I think it is Fair also to think that
in the future political mandates we will
retain the this as an important priority
we are a very active partner of the
European partnership for alternative
approaches to animal testing uh epaa
a public-private partnership grouping
commission services and eight industry
sectors which works towards the
replacement of animal testing for
regulatory purposes together with the
agency in Helsinki and with the
partnership I have just mentioned we are
organizing this new approach
methodologies Workshop next week which
was mentioned already here under the
title towards an animal-free regulatory
system for industrial chemicals the
workshop intends to discuss with
all-involved players the critical needs
to enabling faster progress in this area
we are also closely involved in the
Horizon 2020 project cluster uh
appealingly called aspis and the park
initiative both of which are expected to
bring regulatory solutions for doing
chemical assessments with no new
approach methodologies this important
Works work continues to be addressed
Under The Horizon Europe program the
commission is actively involved in oecd
working groups developing technical
guidelines for new alternative methods
and approaches and in a cooperation with
regulatory agencies for chemicals in the
U.S and Canada to identify how
information from nums can be used to
satisfy regulatory requirements we are
proposing how to modernize
classification criteria under the UN
system such that classification is
possible based on
a new approach methodologies information
instead of based on animal data however
this is a slow alignment process that
needs to go endpoint by end point by
endpoint
and finally you know uh of course we are
preparing the revision of the rich
regulation and we get a lot of uh
questions in this house about the timing
of uh submitting this legislative
proposal and I would like to reassure
the initiators and also the honorable
members of this house that when
preparing the amendments to the rich
regulation the commission is taking the
initiatives the European citizens
initiative recommendation to heart to
Future proof reach with language
flexible to allow the use of new
approach methodologies so to conclude
Madame chair I would say and dear
initiators of
this initiative I would say that the
European commission is not only
declaratively attached to and shares
this objective which is
targeted in this second cluster of the
discussion but we have put in place all
the infrastructure and we are
moving all the army of the Commission in
this direction thank you very much
thank you very much as well and it is
important to hear from the director of
dtmv in the commission all these
important initiatives to proceed with
the phasing count animal testing as soon
as possible and of course we are waiting
for the publication of Fritz as soon as
feasible as well we all know in this
house that it is a decision of behalf of
the colleagues of the Commissioners
thank you very much once again for being
here and contributing to this very
important dialogue congratulations once
again for the initiatives of organizing
this very very important initiative on
phasing out animal testing and Bridging
the Gap between the the invitude data
and the data we need with animal testing
old-fashioned approach and I would like
to go ahead by giving the flow to my
colleague de los Mozilla she's the chair
of the committee on petition the large
the first years
[Music]
well I'm taking
yeah I'm changing
foreign
okay so I'm here on behalf of petty
committee
um we are now starting the third panel
um ECI objective
legislative proposal plotting a road map
to phase out all animal testing in the
European Union before the end of the
current legislative term to present this
ECI objectives I will give now the floor
to Dr Luis abastos a Euro group for
animal then Emily McIver a European
coalition to an animal experiments and
Professor Muriel risks Institute for
risk assessment science division of
Toxicology faculty of Veterinary
veterinary medicine the Utrecht so all
of them they have each one
eight minutes not perhaps all five five
okay yeah because you know the time so
five minutes each one so I'm giving
welcome to Emily Mac you know to Dr
alvisabastos and go ahead thank you very
much
thank you and uh good morning all
um
this Parliament can promote a
win-win-win scenario
for science society and animals just by
supporting once again a plan to
transition to an animal science
because animal experimentation is
causing harm to society and to animals
and when I mention Harms I'm talking
about the harms to animals kept in
Laboratories
but also the Harms
to human and other animal patients who
are still waiting for solutions to their
conditions
I'm talking about the harms to the
environment where we continue dumping
dangerous chemicals
but also the harms to researchers and
technicians
that suffer from the emotional burden of
inflicting harm to other sanctioned
beings it's an endless cycle
and it is to address those Harms
that we are asking for your support to
the third objective of the CCI that asks
specifically that by the end of this of
the current legislative term the
commission commits to a legislative
proposal plotting a road map to phase
out step by step animal experiments in
the EU and this objective is not strange
to you in 2021
95 percent of the members of this house
passed a resolution already mentioned
before on plans and actions to
accelerate the transition to innovation
without the use of animals now you are
joined by more than 1.2 million new
citizens and many scientists in
supporting this eu-wide plan so the
question is
how can we get there
researchers make choices based on the
incentives they have this is how
governments steer and shape science in
the EU and Beyond
and dear researchers using animals
believe that Innovation can lead to
breakthrough Solutions
but they fear that by using new research
models they may face difficulties in
publishing their research and threaten
their access to funds
sometimes research incentives are turned
upside down
I come from a research institute where
scientists were asked to turn towards
animal experiments to be able to publish
in higher impact journals and in turn
have access to bigger grants
we were asked to perform experiments on
animals to be able to survive as
scientists
so what can be a win-win-win scenario
that provides the right incentives to
successfully face the challenges that
come with animal experimentation
we are putting forward six
recommendations for a new roadmap to
transition to an animal science and all
these elements have been adopted or
implemented in some way in other
priority areas
the first is a need for coordination of
actions across commission's directorates
generals agencies and government
Ministries responsible for aspects of
research regulatory testing education
and funding to achieve a strategic focus
on the final goals
and the new commissioner for Animal
Welfare for example could take the
leading role to coordinate actions and
collaborations across all relevant
institutions and stakeholders
and every road map needs Milestones to
focus minds and drive activities towards
the desired goal which in this case
could be Milestones to renew the
research infrastructure review curricula
on Life Sciences or end what is called
in the legislation severe suffering
but besides establishing Milestones it's
important to identify key research areas
to help analyze the continuities of
animals in these areas and how to
replace them
and there's also a need to assess and
expand key infrastructure that can allow
for Fuller exploitation of non-animal
methods and establishing Milestones
identifying the areas of concern and
infrastructure needs will help Define an
appropriate level of funding to support
the replacement of animals in concrete
areas and lastly
a very important aspect of this
transition also echoing the goals of
this Parliament is Education and
Training because researchers Educators
students Regulators they all need
support to change working practices and
have the Knowledge and Skills to embrace
the new methods and the EU already has
extensive and extensive experience in
coordinating the adaptation and
alignment of Education and Training
Systems in member states
researchers are driven to help find
solutions to societal problems but they
are still lacking appropriate and
sufficient incentives and this
Parliament can help researchers to
deliver better and Humane science by
reiterating its support to a concrete
plan to accelerate the transition to
Millennial science thank you
thank you very much now I'm giving the
floor to Emily McIver
thank you very much Madam chair
so this third objective of our ECI is
focused on a very different area from
the first two where regulatory
requirements are directly impacting the
conduct of animal testing
the third objective looks at how we can
adapt research undertaken within the
fields of academic research basic and
applied research and Transit
translational research
this requires a very different kind of
approach regulatory requirements we can
fix with regulations
the context here is very important
and it's important to recognize that the
movement towards replacing animal
research and animal research has been
something developed over many many years
the first EU directive directive
86609 acknowledged the need for the
transition
and then directive
201063 was the second step with a
greater emphasis on promoting better
science through replacing animals and
introducing specific three hours
requirements to replace reduce and
refine animal use there were important
objectives articulated not least that
the ultimate goal is full replacement
but we've all learned that directional
statements aren't enough it's great to
have a goal but goals are meaningless
and the framework that could in an Ideal
World create change could also promote
more of the same
so there have been many calls for Change
and many responses
and I think the commission's response to
the to the citizens initiative stock for
the section
included some very promising words
the commitment to uh communicate and
disseminate information has to a large
extent been met so far with important
work carried out by ekvan to produce
papers on non-animal approaches for
assessing and investigating human
disease
by the epaa the European partnership for
alternatives to animal approaches
has shared information and has in some
cases actually made moves to regulatory
change in the fields of Biologicals and
vaccines testing
but a lot of this is about providing
information and then waiting for people
to take up the suggestions
and facilitating change isn't the same
as requiring action
so when the parliament adopted the
resolution in 2010 the animal protection
Community was disappointed with the
emphasis on reinforcing and intensifying
current efforts and identifying
potential areas where new actions could
be undertaken within the commission's
remit
because we felt that without firm
commitments or any sign of additional
resources there seemed to be little hope
of progress
so we know and have heard the Baseline
is that the numbers of animals used in
the EU isn't changing
I want to point out that what we don't
see in the EU statistics is the number
of animal tests that are carried out
outside the European Union in order to
meet EU regulatory requirements
I also want to point out that the
emphasis on replacement
puts the EU technology and Innovation
sectors ahead of other countries
and our emphasis is on replacement we do
not want to see animal testing simply
exported abroad we want to see
replacement
prioritized and developed here in the EU
to that end
we're asking the commission to take some
specific actions within their remit for
instance under the direct under the
directive
the commission could broaden the amount
of advice provided to Regulators
accessing assessing animal test
proposals
and within the Horizon 20 with Horizon
Europe funding program
we could see evaluations operating a
gold standard when it comes to assessing
the the validity of proposals to conduct
animal research using experts who are
experts in the field who may be able to
advise on alternative approaches for the
sake of improving science as well as
eliminating animal testing
so it's important to learn from our
mistakes
one thing we've all learned is that
words are not enough we've seen very
strong regulatory requirements made
we've seen strong commitments made these
haven't amounted the kind of change that
we need for instance under the chemical
strategy and for instance regarding
testing of Cosmetics on animals
so the next step depends on a broader
proactive approach the transformation
that will be described by the next
speaker and which necessarily includes
all actors and actions but leadership is
essential
and this is the time for new Energy new
focus and new leadership
thank you very much now I'm giving the
floor to the professor Muriel risks
hoitinga
yes thank you my talk is a little longer
than five minutes because we have 20
minutes for this whole session so
I'm going to talk about accelerating the
transition to an animal testing free
world how we could achieve this together
this is my working life cycle it all
started with a literature review at vet
College where I decided to work on
laboratory animal science and first
believed animal study still translated
well to humans I focused on refinement
in my PhD then went on to work for the
Unilever company being the head of the
animal unit and Animal Welfare officer
then moved back to Academia in Denmark
where I became the head of a central
Animal Facility combined with the
professorship with the aim to implement
the three R's in the daily management of
the animal unit
after 10 years I came back to the
Netherlands being again the head of a
central Animal Facility at the Medical
Faculty in Neymar again combined with
the professorship wanting to implement
three Arts I founded the three-hour
Research Center but found the goal to
implement the three hours in itself not
an effective movement and found its
circle on systematic reviews which are a
more effective 3r implementation methods
so I have now my focus fully on
replacements
what are systematic reviews they bring
us the most objective and complete
scientific evidence but strangely enough
are not yet mainstream pre-clinically in
contrast to the clinic evidence-based
medicine where systematic reviews are
performed routinely since the beginning
of the 1990s so why don't we do that for
pre-clinical studies
we did a program in the Netherlands on
pre-clinical systematic reviews
performing workshops coaching and
execution of pre-clinical systematic
reviews funded by the Dutch Health
funding organizations who wanted to know
what the impact was
it has been published in plus one and it
showed a major impact on research and
researchers so I invite you to read this
paper and take this message to you
systematic reviews demonstrate in
general unfortunately a low publication
quality and low translation of animal
studies to humans which indicates a
scientific need for change but we all
know change coincides with resistance
we're only human right
so it needs perseverance and managing
Transitions and for that we have
transition science
transition science uses the multi-level
perspective transition analysis in the
figure you see a lot of arrows don't
worry about that all these processes
influence one another Niche Innovations
at the bottom of the figure refer to
biomedical Innovations like organoids
social technical regimes refer to how we
do things in science and culture and
legislation then at the top you see the
landscape level that's the society level
what does our society want from us
what you try to do in transition science
to identify barriers leverages and
opportunities at these three levels with
a goal to identify opportunities to
accelerate the transition
the Netherlands has the TPI program
which is oriented to animal-free
Innovations the mission is to have
better predictions without animals the
ambition is that the Netherlands can be
a catalyst of the transition towards
animal-free Innovations both nationally
and internationally
the partner program was founded in 2018
and has 11 Partners including a recently
founded young TPI organization
the policy runs in conjunction with
three yards policy to ensure Animal
Welfare as long as animals are needed
what happens in TPI is a beautiful thing
because stakeholders are assembled
funding organizations ngos Academia
Ministries assemble in meetings where it
is discussed what we can do together to
make the move towards accelerating the
transition
to this effect we need mixed methods
research and flexible approaches where
we combine quantitative and qualitative
research we need interdisciplinary but
also transdisciplinary research which is
interdisciplinary research reaching out
to society science is here for society
so needs to talk to society
because providing scientific evidence is
clearly not sufficient to make real
changes we need transition science
and this is an example why we need
social sciences the monocyte activation
test from human blood was validated 25
years ago but first now gets
Incorporated in the European
pharmacopoeia which still not does not
happen in the U.S why does this take so
long we need social sciences to study
why and how we can accelerate
also funding is really important the
Dutch research agenda is funding
transition science on non-animal models
and acceptance and implementation and
I'm involved in one of the consortia
that recently has awarded funding for
these uh for this transition and the
minister of Education recently said that
the Netherlands is thinking about a
second round of funding which is very
good to hear
within the TPI movement ambition
statements and Target images are
published this is one of the recent ones
an ambition statement on innovation in
higher education using fewer laboratory
animals with the aim to move towards
animal-free education and it has been
adopted by the two big university
organizations in the Netherlands the
challenge will be now to implement this
I'd be lucky to experiment with this
multi-level perspective transition
analysis with students and I think this
is really the way forward for all of us
as it leads to co-creative
interdisciplinary learning between
students and teachers with these timely
topics
TPI is Dutch and can of course not do
this alone so TPI has International
ambition and activities
the European approach and I would say
the global approach is crucial to lead
to validation acceptance and
implementation of non-alimal methods
than arms
TPI wishes to start conversations with
other EU member states about validation
of nouns
to find common ground on what is needed
to improve validation so together we can
accelerate our national efforts and
improve our chances to a European
approach
and please feel free to contact our
ministry and Erica Van odd if you're
interested to start on This Road
Together
so let's make it happen together
internationally
phase out animal studies and embrace
Alternatives as soon as possible for the
benefit not only of animals but also of
humans many Norms translate better and
are faster than animal studies
the Science and Technology are here to
make the move
we need to develop a roadmap together
and this should be based more on
evidence when making decisions doing
transdisciplinary research and education
by connecting stakeholders
and do Transition science towards
internationally harmonized legislation
and policies
so with that I would like to thank you
very much for your attention
thank you very much
so now we are going to the questions and
answers so now it's time to give the
floor to the members the first member
that I'm going to give to floor to its
Pablo Arias EVP group
thank you chair
and I'd like to thank the experts as
well who have come here today
to give us their presentations
I'd like to speak about
neurological and and brain
diseases which are very difficult to
treat
nearly half the EU population can have
this type can suffer from this type of
disorder
and this leads to a very high social and
economic costs
and it's a big problem in society today
the brain is a vital and very complex
organ
we need a wide range of techniques based
on different models
we need a human model the artificial one
digital but also the animal one
experiments on animals are on one of the
most highly regulated practices in
Europe so that we can see how diseases
and disorders develop and how we can
treat them
so when treating the central nervous
system one of the main problems is
developing human models that better
mimic these disorders in humans due to
the complexity of the human brain
this can only be done by experimenting
on the brains of animals and this is not
just me speaking this is the what the
scientific Community says
so when we speak of an absolute ban by a
specific date is premature we cannot ban
these types of experiments unless we
wish to see a negative impact on
Research since there are no viable
Alternatives finally we can't lose sight
of
research and competitiveness in Europe
which would which would be highly
affected and we would see a brain drain
out of the EU to other parts of the
world where they can still do these
types of scientific experiments let's
not make some mistakes here based on
ideology
let's base our uh our actions on
scientific arguments and this is what we
should mention in all the debates being
held
and perhaps the experts and perhaps the
commission as well can tell us how you
can Ensure
in the coming steps that we keep this
scientific community in mind
which upholds testing on animals
thank you now I'll give the floor
to Miss Carolyn Rose
thank you very much chairman
the 23 million animals the number of
animals who are raised and killed every
year in the European Union to carry out
tests on them of course you think of
rats and mice and rabbits but also cats
and dogs horses primates and even fish
we're looking at almost 2 000 beagles
who are raised in enclosed areas before
being tested on
so they're sold to Laboratories
and what sort of Life are they living
these animals we import hundreds of
primates primates who are raised in
horrific conditions in Madagascar the
2010 directive on protection of animals
for the use of scientific purposes
constitutes a major step in the right
direction
and it means that they should
prioritize
the use of non-animal testing but this
is obviously not being respected
so we need to
make sure that we're reducing animal
testing
we know that testing on animals are less
efficient than on than other
methods we see that all sorts of animal
testing don't work when transferred to
humans why is this not working or do we
lack coordination we need a global plan
for example to train researchers in
terms of what Avail alternatives are
available we also need to adopt very
clear language
for example by Banning tests on animals
if there are alternatives available it's
high time that we have a transition to
animal-centered policies and I'd like to
thank those who've started this
initiative the citizens initiative the
millions of citizens who've signed this
millions of volunteers who've been
who've mobilized to gather these
signatures and who are mobilizing to try
and bring a stop to this unacceptable
suffering we also need a commissioner
dedicated to Animal Welfare as well
thank you now I'm giving the floor to
Silvia Limer
is here
thank you chair
thank you to The Experts who've come
here today Europe should have play a
leadership role when it comes to
scientific research and innovation
because historically we've brought
forward a great
forward in knowledge and because we want
to be leaders in the development of
medicines our priority should be to have
the best environment for protecting
human health while keeping our ethics in
mind we need to have conditions that
allow projects to move forward in a
competitive way
of course we should have research that
allows us to have
in vitro and not in Vivo experiments but
these models are necessary
we need to have a deep deeper knowledge
of diseases
toxicity and efficiency of substances
can't only be seen at the cellular level
we also need to look at the whole
organism of course AI can help us reach
conclusions however
difficulties alluded to
offshoring this type of research to
third countries where there is no
regulation whatsoever
let's learn from what has already
happened with
energy
environmental goals
have unrealistically
brought in alternative
uh energies which has led to importing
of of a fuel with even a higher carbon
footprint let's listen to our scientist
they want to ethically come up with new
therapy therapies and they are the ones
who would prefer to use in vitro models
as long as they're able to give us the
proper information but they're clear
that testing on animals is necessary the
commission says that it wasn't doesn't
want to raise any obstacles but don't
you think this is contradictory when
you're changing the regulation and
setting such clear goals that are not
keeping in mind that what the scientific
Community is telling us
should we not
simply before we change regulation
should we not prevent such hopeful
therapies from coming about thank you
Mrs de la Pisa
Anna Silvia Limer
ick
thank you very much especially to our
guests but for 20 years now in the EU
there's a comprehensive ban on animal
testing for Cosmetics data that have
been gathered
in Third Country show that third country
products produced in this way can't be
sold in the UK but apart from Cosmetics
they're medicines that can be very
useful to save lives and medical safety
doesn't exist without animal testing
because the way that the effects happen
and the toxicity and detox
detoxicity and accumulation processes
cannot be simulated in a petri dish
this is also a task of basic research
animal testing is always a question of
what's the best for Animal Welfare the
fewest tests on animals the smallest
interventions and the use of analgesics
as well and rightly so they are a very
strictly regulated it's not a question
of ruling through emotions and saying
that Cosmetics have to be regulated by
our hearts while risking the lives of
millions of people
you want animal protection okay well as
a vet I also want that
knowledge a complete animal testing free
world is not possible unless you are
willing to endanger the lives of
millions of people including our most
vulnerable groups our babies and
children thank you
gracias thank you very much now I'm
giving the floor to Marlene Boucher
thank you very much chairman ladies and
gentlemen
first of all thank you to the authors of
this ECI stop cruelty
and their participation here for two
years now the EU Parliament has asked
for the development of a plan to stop
animal testing in industry and research
because despite the fact that animal
testing on Cosmetics uh being banned for
for a while
nevertheless many of these sort of tests
are carried out and it's because an
impact
substance can fall under other
legislation such as chemicals or
medicines in which case animal testing
is allowed but ninety percent of con
constituent Cosmetics is indeed
subject to other regulations so this
basically doesn't have much of an impact
we know that over 5 million animals have
been killed in this form of testing so
we have to shift to different forms of
method alternative methods as well and
they have to become the gold standard
for that behind this demand they're 1.5
million citizens in the EU who want to
see politics do something and deliver on
this thank you
thank you very much now I'm giving the
floor to pascala Limon EPP
thank you very much
thank you ladies and gentlemen first of
all thank you for the very important
input we've heard today thank you for
all the experts who've taken the floor
the ban on the use of animal testing on
Cosmetics is something I support
wholeheartedly the cosmetics and
directive can has established very
important basis for this we need to look
at loopholes that might need to be
closed and I think we all agree on that
however it is very problematic and this
come takes me back to
what our friend who is a vet said if we
have testing on animals it's necessary
for medicine so we can't necessarily ban
that
animals used for scientific purposes set
to a bar for how this can be done that
it should be avoided where it is
possible
this leads us to a fundamental question
of how in the future we're going to deal
with animal testing in the medicine
where it can't be replaced whether
aren't all terms should I said this as
well
I'm not citing myself I'm citing
somebody called Professor Dr Matthias
horneth from The Institute of
micromedicinal
um
Institute he asked me to quote him
he said
at the current in the current state of
affairs and for the foreseeable future
we cannot exclude animal testing without
by using Alternatives because that would
allow us to lose
the possibility of doing progress on
researching into tumors
but also microbiome research
microbiology would be made impossible
and that means that medicinal provision
would be endangered at the highest level
and in developing new medicines would be
dependent on third countries also a
large number of high qualified
scientists working in academic and
non-academic institutions and on the
base of animal testing models
would be forced to leave if they're a
ban in the EU that would risk jobs in
basic research but also apply to
research
and the uh
training of future scientists would be
impinged on end of quote these are ideas
that I'd like to flow into the debate
and we need to create Clarity here
obviously as we have a directive Banning
tests on animals where it can be avoided
that's something we support in
Parliament but where it's not possible
and here we're talking about
forms of research that require this then
we have to leave the door open for
animal testing because our continent
cannot be deprived of this if we're to
ensure strategic autonomy and the health
of our citizens thank you
thank you very much now Jana Tom renew
group
thank you chair uh I'm sorry I had to
went away in between can I ask the
question from initiators of
okay I'll take it like agreement uh yes
uh sorry I missed maybe a part but I was
in the very beginning and you know that
Parliament is kind of slice of society
we are from different backgrounds I'm
not scientist I'm not biologist but I'm
journalist which means that I have a
habit and a skill to check information
in the very beginning you showed the
video clip which was very shocking about
a beautiful lady coloring her lashes
with mascara and you know there was
bleeding suffering rabbit in there I
just sent
um I I contacted a few academics in
Estonia and asked them if this is
adequate image I would say said no way
nowadays there is no mascara that
requires such kind of animal treatment
so this is emotional I understand that
so my first question is what is your
estimation how many people out of this
1.4 million who signed initiative made
the decision emotionally for here in
this house we cannot allow us to be
emotional we have to rely on certain
arguments and my second question is as
due to design of this healing we didn't
hear
um many counter arguments are there any
arguments of your opponents which you
believe are valid thank you
thank you very much now till we met
Green's group yes
against myths and rumored staff facts so
I think we should organize as European
Parliament as Envy committee a visit to
those labs so that we can see by
ourselves the reality of the testing of
millions of animals that is be done but
first of all I want to thank all the
association ngos and mostly also the
scientists that work for that and the
citizens that scientists petition uh
which was really really important
because what we all want I think we
agree in that we want efficient reliable
timely yes also ethical uh testing and
therefore and Louisa bastos was saying
it and that is my question to the
commission very clearly we need a road
map with concrete Milestones to phase
out animal testing I know this is not
going to happen overnight but we have
foreseen since 2010 uh where the
directive on animal in science we are
focusing on would you sing refining
replacing where the phasing out is
foreseen so it's already some time and
by the way also to control these three
Arts we are not doing enough to really
Implement them in some research sectors
speaking about tumors sticking to animal
testing that avoids us from progressing
I'm speaking for example regarding
breast cancer so we could advance that
in research in treatment if we would use
the names so animal testing is at the
end of the day not very efficient as it
is not always or rarely transfable we
are not 80 kilos rats or even dogs it's
far from transferable as I said it's
expensive it takes a long time
much longer for example than working
directly on human cells so please let's
make the names a political priority
adopt the regulation educate also The
Regulators to get out of what I call a
tradition it's a tradition and therefore
I found it very interesting also that we
should really make psycho societal
studies while we why we really stick to
this tradition I know change makes
always is always frightening but here we
have really to analyze something that we
want since 2010 that we have in our Au
legislative tax that we don't achieve to
make it a priority so we need to come
away from the animal tastic that are far
from always being validated now we are
focusing yeah names have to be validated
but who was validating all the time the
animal testing so let's stop this cruel
animal testing and I really would like
to organize this visit I can also do
that into the lab so it's not about
ideology it's not about emotions it's
just about facts it's about science we
have the tier
gigantia those are signs I don't think
all those signs also here in the room
are doing that because of ideology we're
doing that because we want efficient
testing and that is based for on the
future on nams we had to phase out
animal testing which is cruel and not
necessary thank you
thank you very much now I'm giving the
floor
to the ex Express five minutes
among all of you so if you want you can
use the same order at the beginning
I hear uh emotions and the belief that
animal studies can predict so much for
humans I believe that for a long time
until I started doing systematic reviews
so let's try and get away from emotions
only and get the facts on the table and
those are scientifically valid methods
doing systematic reviews and I think we
can really get a better debate that way
I also heard uh immunology and brain
diseases are increasing why not focus
more research on prevention it's
becoming very expensive to get
treatments for all those diseases and we
should focus a lot more on prevention
we can also do different research like
epidemiological research Parkinson's
disease is probably related to the use
of pesticides that's a very worrying
thing pesticide Parkinson is on the rise
so we should focus on those kind of
topics
and then in the covert time we've seen
we can certainly be a lot faster in
improving vaccines so that is also
something to take into account when
doing new research that it is possible
to do more Alternatives and fewer animal
studies and get vaccines approved in one
year time instead of 15. and then Noms
um somebody said the competitiveness of
the EU and people will move away let's
use the nums to start new markets within
the EU Norms are here to stay there is a
very
um Institute in the U.S everybody knows
it I think this institute it's a
fantastic Institute gaining a lot of
economy and attraction so let's do those
things too we can do so in in Europe and
we have good companies already
so I think that was my response to the
things I heard so Louisa or Emily do you
want to add
thank you again and thank you for for
the the fruitful debate
um
I would like to add that
when when talking about neurological
diseases or other human diseases we have
a very serious problem we have
potential treatments that continue to
fail when they come to clinical trials
and part of the problem is that we
continue relying on non-animal model or
better yet non-human animal models to to
understand the diseases and try to find
treatments for those diseases so
recognizing the limitations of
animal-based studies is a first step to
be taken to be able to advance science
and healthcare because patients continue
missing effective treatments for
neurological and other diseases and
there is no compromise to be made
between animal protection and human
health I don't think anyone is defending
that
but thanks to our mistrust on the new
methods they are being developed on the
right in the right way we need to
understand a different way in which we
are looking at and developing
scientifically these new methods that do
not involve the use of animals because
it's a new it's a new world it's a new
field that we want to do it right for
animals but for humans specifically
and internationally into
um the internationalization aspect of
science is obviously very important we
need a worldwide transition but the
world needs an inspiration and
Leadership and then you can lead by
example as it is for cosmetics
and scientific opinions differ because
we heard here about some opinions of
scientists but many leading scientists
are also calling for and supporting this
transition and part of this transition
is to ensure that scientists and
Industry and every stakeholder has the
means to advance this transition
thank you and
thank you very much honorable members
for the questions
picking up on the point about prevention
of disease we've we know about
treatments uh there is a enormous
failure rate in the translation of drugs
that have passed uh safety and efficacy
trials in animals and then fail at
clinical stage
a better understanding of human biology
will help to produce better
understanding of how to prevent disease
and this is especially important in the
field of advancing health research so
it's it's important to look at this from
all angles
in terms of the point about Cosmetics
testing on animals every piece of
material put out by the five organizing
ngos of this citizens initiative was
fact checked carefully there is evidence
scientific papers have been written
about testing Cosmetics ingredients on
animals nothing that has been presented
in the area of Cosmetics testing by our
organizations has not passed a rigorous
fact check
and I would say in in the field of
biomedical research yes it's not about
ideology it's about science and we have
new tools available to us new
technologies available to us that were
never available when animal research
techniques were first developed we
really can break down those barriers and
the barriers are holding us back so if
we if we really want to press ahead and
make the transformation we have to
understand that barriers need to be
broken and there is progress to be made
and it is being made by thousands of
biomedical researchers who already do
not use animals and who are relying on
on understanding of human biology first
thank you very much now I'm giving the
floor the floor to
um misla patha Santos head of unit
Health Innovations and in DG research
and Innovations and ecosystems
five minutes
thank you very much so Dear honorable
members of the European Parliament thank
you for organizing this hearing and I
would like to thank you as well to the
representatives of the European citizens
initiative
um
and congratulate them for the success of
having managed to to put it forward so
yeah I will focus on the third objective
which in my opinion is certainly the
most ambitious a full band on the use of
test animals not only for Cosmetics or
regulatory purposes but also in research
and education in which most animals
are used we are convinced that this
objective will be rich
but only one science has progressed
sufficiently to offer adequate
non-animal methods for all needs I think
this has been repeatedly said by by
several speakers
as you rightly point out a substantial
and sustained investment in the
development validation and uptake of non
and non-animal alternative methods is
key to reach this Target and that's
where we will do our best in order to to
support this this objective
because we do care about the animals
about their well-being but we are also
aware of the limitations that have also
been mentioned of the animal models
as you know we have been a major
supporter of of this area of research
with more than one billion euros
allocated during the last two decades
over 300 research and Innovation
projects that have developed a variety
of non-animal methods and strategies
some of which are used already in
research and on regulatory purposes as
has already been mentioned as well
but the reality is the uptake is the
slow
and more needs to be done to educate to
increase the awareness and to facilitate
the use and what is really that reality
as well is more science needs to be
developed in order to ensure that for
all those areas where the
non-alternative matters are not yet
available more funding will be allocated
for
so although if and this although the
budget to this area has constantly
progressed over the years Horizon 2020
Horizon Europe are funding ambitious
research projects I will already
mentioned two very prominent examples
which are the aspis cluster currently
developing non-alternative methods to
improve the accuracy the speed but also
the affordability which is an important
point the affordability of chemical
safety testing
um and also a park a co-funded
partnership with member states to risk
to chemical risk assessment which is
currently fostering the acceptance and
use of non-ath animal methods by
Regulators as an example they are
currently developing a toolbox for
implementing safe and sustainable by
Design framework promoting the use of in
silico tools
and risk a skin chemical risk assessment
and the funding allocated to support the
development of non-alternative methods
will continue from the commission side
you are certainly aware that the topic
is currently open with a submission
deadline of 19 September 23 where
persistence where precisely we are
targeting biomedical research scenarios
with limited trans translational value
of animal-based approaches and where the
highest rate of animal juice or several
of or severe animal suffering
another topic to support more the uptake
the uptake in particular by Regulators
is put forward as well with a deadline
in April 2024
aiming to support the training of
regulators on alternative to animal
testing it's aiming to a crosstalk
between different legislative sectors
including industrial chemicals
Pharmaceuticals and food ingredients
it is equally likely that the Innovative
Health Initiative joined undertaking
successor of the IMI will continue
investing in the development of
alternative to animal testing and will
also Foster increasingly the uptake by
the health industry
a relevant call topic is plenty will
launched later this year
and further funding we expect to put
forward in the following calls of
horizon Europe in the Years 2025 to 2027
because we leave that support to
Alternative is crucial to advance the
scientific knowledge that will
ultimately lead to the facing out of
animal testing
we are very grateful for you
representatives of the European citizen
Initiative for all the ideas that you
have suggested that you are requesting
us to put forward to accelerate this
transition we have listened carefully
and we have appreciated a lot intense
debate that has been
held today here in this forum and
believe me we are working hard together
with the other strategies of the
European commission and in in
collaboration also with the joint
Research Center to see how much we can
be ambitious and puts further forward
some of those ideas us of course as much
as science allows for for the time being
I think that I am the last speaker of
the of the commission and because of
that I would like to to before giving
the floor back to thank you members of
the parliament to thank you also
representatives of the European citizen
initiative safe cruelty free Cosmetics
coming to Europe without animal testing
for your views on this important issue
of phasing out animal testing for
regulatory Testing Research and
education this initiative reminds us all
how Animal Welfare reminds reminds us
strong concerns for European citizens as
I said we have listened very carefully
your intervention your ideas and we are
currently very busy preparing the reply
in form of communication that we hope
will be adopted at the latest by 25 of
July in this the communication we will
reply Point by point to all the
different issues you have in place
thanks for that
thank you very much
we are at the end of these three panels
and these interesting reading organized
by Petty Agri and MB or NB rempeti it
doesn't matter the order but I'm Petty
so
um I want to thank you all very much for
your interventions and we are at the end
of this public hitting and on behalf of
these three um committees I would like
once again to thank you all for your
foot full debate and the interesting
contributions of the points Rising today
the reading gave us time to hear and
weight the potential of the initiative I
want to thank all the speakers who
brought some additional light on the
issue at stake a special thanks of
course to the organizers for presenting
to us this important topic thanks to the
commissioner uh this morning at the
beginning for her intervention and
reflection to the EC representatives and
to our colleagues who took the floor
today in fact it is
um no and I would like to thank you the
Secretariat for the you know three
committees for the precious work and
support and nothing else I hope so that
this work can help to these three
committees to continuing to improve our
legislation so thank you very much